a lot of people are turning towards
artificial intelligence and Robo
advisors to get their financial advice I
just I see a lot of financial advisors
putting it into their practices I was
just wondering is it a dangerous thing
is it a good thing it's both
um Ai and Robo investing is is good it's
there's nothing wrong with any of it
um especially where you're dealing with
a very small account and you're just
getting started and it causes you at a
low cost to get started as an investor
but if I was managing a million dollars
am I letting a chat bot do that no don't
think so
yeah really I mean AI stuff's very
impressive
um we were I was looking at a meeting
this morning some of the stuff that
we're going to be able to do with it
it's uh it's ridiculous yeah uh how how
cool some of this stuff is but with it
comes the danger of no human oversight
you are always in charge of your money
not your financial advisor whether it's
AI whether it's Robo whether it's an
individual human being you have to
understand where the money's going you
are in charge of it